three two one action in facebook
currency news submitted by drama for yo
mama a Facebook announces its own
cryptocurrency called Libre
it's a Libra I know you're a Libra I'm a
Libra this one's pretty interesting so
Facebook everyone's favorite privacy
protector oh yeah yeah they're looking
to do their own cryptocurrency that will
basically they already are gonna roll
out with 27 partners including Visa
MasterCard yes
that's kind of good for other group for
anything it's good for awareness of
cryptocurrencies which i think is what
just happen with Bitcoin Bitcoin just
[ __ ] exploded I think almost a couple
days after this was announced right I
think that legit amazes it and [ __ ]
Google searches for Bitcoin spiked
through the [ __ ] roof like after this
was all my mom yes
and then I hear a big company like
Facebook and then visa jump on board and
then all the other ones that you just
name and I'm like oh [ __ ] this thing is
gonna last it's like here to say it is a
lot of partners though are approaching
Libra warily because they and they only
signed non-binding agreements to join
because they didn't know if they wanted
to be obligated to promote Libra because
they could easily back out if they
didn't like where it was going like if
maybe the project had a problem or a
major hiccup they could at least pull
out and be like we didn't really have
much to do with it it's all good but a
lot of people in the crypto space are
extremely wary of Libra because it's
basically a centralized cryptocurrency
which means that which is opposite what
most crypto supporters want a lot of the
idea behind that's what the Bitcoin
white paper was about is decentralized
finance right I can do it Ament with you
and we don't have to have anyone's
permission to do it it all happens via
blockchain so no one doesn't have a
block team well this one won't have a
bunch it's the same technology but under
the watchful eye of Facebook it's
centralized centrally so that it's all
happening every gear every wire every
lever is pulled at Facebook so like when
your transaction happens it goes through
Facebook and Facebook knows that you
transacted with Joe or you bought
something from
whereas all the other current oh and
those and that's good
well it's decentralized people don't
know what you did last night they don't
know where you went and whose drinks you
bought and all the [ __ ] that we all do
are you familiar with cryptocurrency
I've heard about it but I don't I have
no idea what it's a new soft drink it's
really good taste ease fruity but not
too fruity okay so do you get it and
I've heard about it like a thousand
million times and I'm still like huh the
idea behind Libra is almost perfect for
someone like you who doesn't know crypto
but who thinks they're maybe gonna
invest in cryptocurrency because they're
saying like hey we're a cryptocurrency
so that means like mom and dad and
grandma can buy it and use it because
it's it's what's called a stable coin
mm-hm so it's always gonna be worth the
same amount of money like say it's a
dollar it's always gonna be worth one
dollar right but but Facebook is
basically attacking venmo and all these
other payment provider PayPal right
because they're saying hey but we're a
cryptocurrency which is hot right now
because everyone's seen Bitcoin
exploding and all stuff so people are
going holy [ __ ] like you if they're
already partnered with all these people
that's a huge opportunity for me even
though the coin will never go up in
value in order to use this
cryptocurrency you have to buy what's
called a note all right well you know
what that is no you you wanted to find
it foreveryone guys a node allows you to
confirm transactions on the network
right
but the buy-in price is 10 million
dollars per node so who the [ __ ] is
gonna buy it what big companies and
that's another Wow the etherion
community is like what the [ __ ] is this
the web community the etherium community
what is that again I'll let you explain
it to the people they're like a race
like Vulcans pretty good the point is is
that think about like this okay you have
a life so you don't know these things
pretend you have a kindergarden on this
whole side okay explain it to us
what Libra is trying to do is just make
it so that people and say Mexico or
South America or wherever can pay for
things easily through well I guess you
have to go a step further back which is
correct your phone to venmo side which
is what is cryptocurrency
thank you where it's it's right now the
dollar isn't backed by anything so
that's why the [ __ ] price is
fluctuating all the time and we're like
well what the [ __ ] like they can just
are they just printing money all the
time like what is my money really
worries back in the day it was gold
uhm and now it's not anything there's a
gold standard right and then evil people
can print out as much money as they want
and it's a few people are controlling
that power whereas Bitcoin it's just
open yeah and it's a finite amount right
there's always gonna be like 23 million
bitcoins and that's it that's all that's
why Bitcoin has a lot of value to people
because anybody in any country including
Venezuela where your currency just got
overly inflated because of government
printing evil people printing money
exactly so their currency in Venezuela
just went through the [ __ ] roof it's
like you can with inflation so you can
have like 10 trillion of their currency
and it doesn't even buy you anything
it's difficult because first you have to
understand a little bit of economics in
a certain way and then you understand
how money works and and and where it
comes from and all that and there's like
a lot of good documentaries out there
where it explains all of those steps so
you it's this the way that you get
yourself into this there is phases
there's phase it's like there's just you
got a go to 101-102 like because we're
we're starting with Libre and all that
you gotta have all this knowledge of
what crypto is yeah period but that's
what a lot of people in crypto in the
ignorant community your favorite it
people who follow a belief system which
is like let's decentralize payments for
everyone in the world make it fear
that's right so that you don't have to
worry about whatever the [ __ ] your
governments up to you can just transact
with who you want transact with when you
want to transact something there it's
like saying let's put money into the
power of the people and not in the power
of the government yes so that's what
crypto currencies ideology is if you
were in Indonesian right now and you
wanted to pay for something with a card
they don't like you very much because
they pay 5% to Visa or MasterCard or
whatever so with crypto currencies you
can do it for a very minimal fee because
there's no need to secure your network
with mainframes and IT people and all
this stuff
where is really going to the whoever is
running the note yeah but if there's
only work connect amount of crypto how
does everyone just invest in it like I
heard is that they're divisible
so like one Bitcoin can be divided up
like I think it's a million times or
something it's a it's a time yeah that's
what some people pay for things with
0.00005 bitcoins and that's still like
500 bucks
because it's worth so much it's like a
bitcoins worth were like 15,000 right
now it's worth 12,000 I think so like if
you have 6,000 you bought you'd only own
half a Bitcoin exactly so it's not the
whole units yeah so you don't have to
pay for things with one Bitcoin you pay
for things with is that the same thing
for it there yeah yeah so different can
be broken up as well yeah so then now
with Facebook coming in and doing all
this why are these big companies backing
them up if it's going against the whole
cryptocurrency why money they see it as
another marketplace that they can
utilize because they're targeting people
that are farmers people in Southeast
Asia who don't use payments processors a
lot like a lot of those people can join
this financial system because a lot of
those people have smartphones so does
that mean these big companies are
partnering up are they owning the nodes
yes exactly they would be running the
nodes that are confirming the
transactions on the network and then so
that's why a lot of people a lot of
people need the affinity
they don't like it but then there's a
there's a group and of the etherium
community that wants to court Libra and
the popularity of Facebook's name and
how they're bringing grandma and yeah
and they want to buy a node with a
etherium node there's a fun for a theory
'm where a bunch of community tokens are
together in this fund it's like an
aetherium group fund right and they want
to buy a node to both legitimize Libra
and and I'm sorry I'm so sorry I'm so
sorry
welcome to the Future it's really
stressed out you guys it's like it's
like um wait keep going with what you're
saying
okay okay they want to legitimize a
theory I'm using Libra right so a lot of
people hear a theorem and like what the
[ __ ] is that right but if they know that
etherium is apart somehow of the each of
the Libra ecosystem mastercard exactly
that it legitimizes etherion more to the
minds of the regular joe and there's a
lot of people who founded aetherium
there's a guy named flattens am fear who
was one of the co-founding had vlad
Zamfir and the real person was you like
that's not cool he's a real person and
he's an interesting mother he's a very
jaded person he's 17 year old with like
pimple face oh no that's Vladimir that's
oh never mind that's not Vlad Zamfir
yeah that's uh that's the table yeah
Batali do you remember I just I loved
all this [ __ ] okay so Vlad Zamfir he
attacked this Community Fund for wanting
to be part of Lieber and run a node for
Libra because it legitimizes a
decentralized yeah which goes against
the whole exactly and so there's a war
going on in the crypto space right now I
call what does that look like yeah I
just wanted nerds more like this I'm so
mad they're typing with these right yeah
basically yeah so the war is basically
like people like I we want to keep the
decentralized nature of aetherium intact
and then there's people were like yeah
but at what cost we want to be
mainstream I centralized all the way I
don't want people to know about my
transactions and what I do with my money
I'm in-between because I think
institution helps keeping it safe yes
with safety with if you get stole if
people heist your things yes you can you
can ask the government to help you get
it back so what I personally love about
it is less about me and I know that
sounds so lame I've already done pretty
good on this stuff I'm fine but the
people in Southeast Asia the farmers all
these guys who get ripped off by Visa
MasterCard and they don't have like
banking system they can trust at all
they don't even get access to bank yeah
they're [ __ ] they get to hang out and
do nothing yeah that's why I actually a
lot of Asians don't put money in the
bank but that's not what's known about
the community right that the mean is
that they just put money in the mattress
they don't trust banks but it's really
that they their friends can't access
banks like their neighbors can access
banks like only the rich in those areas
can access banks because the banks want
nothing to do with the poor people yeah
or you have money in there and the next
day they're like oh no it's gone exactly
yeah and it's like why all our bankers
went bad or it was never there we
printed you want to steal from you guys
yeah people in the bottom beautiful
countries it's really [ __ ] dangerous
do people in Venezuela beg for Bitcoin
because they can use it and people will
take it yeah can you imagine having
working all your life and you saved up
like a million dollars right and you're
about to retire and all of a sudden it's
worth nothing yeah and then you're
starving and you worked so hard to
become wealthy and you have nothing to
give that like to your kids or anything
mhm that's basically what happened to
Venezuela and also another African
country I forgot which one it was but
they were they had to pay millions of
dollars just for like bread Wow it's
good bein Zimbabwe I found you're right
you're right to counter your argument
real quick crypto so volatile how can
you trust crypto over my currency which
just ran up because of inflation but my
whole thing is kryptos never gone below
a certain point for everyone who says
crypto so volatile it's only
hockey-stick like this and yes it goes
down but then it goes up and it goes
down and it goes up never crashes below
the previous floor that was established
which is because there's demand for it
and that's sad what the [ __ ] no no it's
just demand for this will make you man
goodbye now
[Music]